WESLEY CHUN: Hello everybody,
welcome to Google IO.
How is it so far?
[APPLAUSE]
WESLEY CHUN: You guys have at
least one electronic device
that I don't have yet,
so I'm jealous.
That's great.
I'm glad you're here.
I'm kind of surprised you guys
aren't going to the Pac-Man
session or the App Engine
2.0 session.
What are you guys here for?
[INAUDIBLE].
WESLEY CHUN: All right.
So some of you guys know that
I give Python training
classes, and I'm just going to
tell you that hey, I'm going
to give this entire talk
in plain text.
Any Vim or Emacs users
out there?
Awesome.
Well, I was going to give you
guys a demo of a really cool
Python tool that I actually
have. I actually did create
this presentation using plain
text because I, like you guys,
am a programmer and
I prefer to do my
presentations that way.
But sometimes I'm not
allowed to do that.
So I have a little PC that I
have in my backpack with me
and I actually used that a few
minutes ago, just before I
came in here.
And I used that.
I don't know if you guys can
see it really clearly.
But I really don't work
with tools like
PowerPoint really well.
But I work with Python
really well.
And if I can make a Python
script to actually help me
build my presentation, then
that's a much cooler thing to
do than to have to--
like on a plane kit.
Have you guys tried to do
PowerPoint on a plane?
OK, it doesn't work
out really well.
So skipping to the end here.
Hopefully it's still going.
Oh, it even does a countdown
and it actually starts the
slide show and it
turns it into an
IO talk too, magically.
So anyway, that's
what my PC does.
But it's dead now.
Because I'm using a Mac.
All right, so welcome
to Python at Google.
A few intro stuff.
So some tips on social stuff, if
you guys want to be social.
You could also be antisocial
and not do anything.
And a feedback link, which I'll
also give you guys the QR
code as well as the
URL at the end.
OK, so before I start, I just
wanted to let you guys know
that this talk is going to be
slightly different than any of
the other talks you're
going to.
I'm glad that you
guys are here.
I'm glad this is at the
end of the day.
You guys have gone to
pre-technical sessions and I
just want this to be more
informal, more relaxed, just
for you guys to wind down the
day before the party tonight.
All right, there will be
a lot of toys there.
So I'm going to start out with
bringing up quotes from three
really well-known people,
computer scientists.
And the thing that's very
interesting about these three
gentleman is that they are
experts in programming
languages that are not Python.
And I think they're giving us
some sort of endorsement in
one way or the other.
So we'll start with Larry Wall,
he's, as you know, the
creator of Perl.
So 13 years ago somebody else,
why is Perl worse than Python?
And that was the
answer he gave.
You can take it for what it's
worth, but I was pretty happy
when I saw it.
I think the Python community,
in general,
appreciates that quote.
The next one is by Bruce
Eckel, he's a pretty
well-known author of Thinking
in Java, Thinking in C++.
And he came up with these
phrases that actually became
so popular that we decided
to use them as slogans on
t-shirts at Python
conferences.
So they're more cerebral, so you
might have to think about
them a little bit more, but I
think he's just trying to give
what his feelings were at the
time that he made the quotes.
The last one is by Peter Norvig,
who's a big member of
the list community.
And he also has nice words to
say about Python as well.
And he also works at Google
like a couple of us.
All right, so this is a slide.
It's the last time you're
going to be
your favorite language.
So just inhale, sigh, and
relax because your next
favorite language
will be Python.
One line.
All righty, so why
are you here?
Well, hopefully you heard some
good word of mouth about
Python or you got involved in
some open source project or
some development tool that uses
a lot of Python, like
Django, App Engine.
Or you found out a lot of big
companies use it, like Google
and Yahoo and NASA and Lucas
Film and all those companies.
And/or specifically, you want
to hear how Google uses it.
Or you had no choice because you
were forced by your boss
to come here.
Hopefully that's not the case,
otherwise you should be
smiling either way.
Being forced to come to IO?
Yeah, right.
Great.
OK, so I'm going to assume
you are a blank slate.
All right, so apologies for all
of you guys out there who
are Python veterans.
How many Python veterans
out there more
than five plus years?
Wow.
That's pretty good.
Some of you guys have never
heard of Python before five
years, right?
So I'm going to get the rest
of you guys up to speed, so
you veterans, you guys
can go get a drink
and come back later.
OK?
So the rest of the talk is going
to be broken up into
four main pieces.
First, I'm going to do the
quickie, high level intro to
what is Python.
Then I'm going to show you what
other companies have been
doing with it, so that's
Python not at Google.
And then I'll dive into specific
Google things, and
then lastly, I'll
talk about you.
All right, so a little bit
of background about me.
I've been a software engineer
for the last 20 years.
Currently at work I'm a
developer advocate at Google
representing our cloud products,
like App Engine.
Outside of work I'm actually
a Python advocate.
So I've been teaching for 20,
almost 30 years and at least
12 of those are with Python.
So I've been around
the block a lot.
I have about 14.5 of Python.
And more about me later.
We have a special guest
in the audience.
Up here at the front is Guido
van Rossum, or [? Fee-do ?]
if you know how to
pronounce Dutch.
He's the creator of Python
or the BDFL, Benevolent
Dictator For Life.
[APPLAUSE]
WESLEY CHUN: And it's pretty
much due to him that set my
entire career.
So I owe him at least
that much.
He works as a software engineer
at Google on the App
Engine team, where he works on
Python libraries, API design,
UI programming, and
developer tools.
He has slightly a few more years
of Python experience
than I have, so I'm
afraid to say.
And so he's here to keep me
honest. He'll throw tomatoes
at me if I say something
wrong, and he'll also
help out with Q&A.
All right, so what is Python?
In a nutshell, it's an
object-oriented programming language.
Some people like to immediately
say, oh, it's a
scripting language.
But you know, I have to say,
in the last 14 years, I've
used it for a little bit
more than scripting.
All the way to like servers that
do back end work that you
don't see, testing, automation
frameworks, things like that.
So it's more than
just scripting.
Of course, that's one of
the things you can do.
Like many other scripting
languages, Python is
interpreted, but it's also
bytecode-compiled.
So when you run your script the
first time, it's got to go
through that compilation
phase.
But if you don't change your
code the next time you run
your script, it's not going to
have that start up penalty.
The syntax is very simple, yet
robust. That makes the
language easy to read.
And because it's easy to read,
for beginners that makes it
easy to learn.
And if you're working in a
group, then it's easy to
maintain because chances are
your code is going to outlive
you at your current place
of employment.
And one of the last things that
people say about Python
is that it is batteries
included.
That means that when you
download the tarball or the
zip file or the MSI file, you
pretty much have everything
you need to actually get
a small task done.
Don't really have to go and
download anything else.
Another thing that people don't
know is that Python just
turned 20 two months ago.
20 years old.
Can you believe that?
It was released on the internet
around Valentine's
Day of 1991.
Maybe you haven't heard of it
until recently because it's
mostly been word of mouth.
And that includes no word of
mouth, so a little bit more
about that later.
But I have to say that in my
experience, I've seen Python
take a pretty significant
jump in popularity
over the last decade.
Especially when it comes
to job listings.
I will have to say that I've
been very fortunate in my
career to have been able to work
as a software engineer
using Python as a primary
development tool to actually
build real products
that people use.
But finding those jobs is
actually pretty difficult, or
at least it was 10 years ago.
But that's not as much
the case anymore.
A couple of years ago Safari
Books Online asked me to give
a webinar on Python and it was
kind of odd for me because I'd
never been asked.
I've never been approached
to do that before.
And I asked, why are you guys
asking me to do a talk on
Python now?
And they also said that we've
all noticed a jump in
popularity what Python
as well.
And I asked them, so what are
the top search terms that
people use when they
go and look for
another book to download?
And they gave me the list.
You can see there, pretty
interesting list. I'm expecting
Android and Chrome
to have creeped into this
over the last two years.
It's also become
a fan favorite.
So for people that actually do
discover Python, they have
really good feelings about it.
So TLB is one of those marketing
things where you can
either decide you like
it or you think
it's complete hogwash.
And so what they do is they sort
of take a measurement as
far as, what is the
market share
for programming language?
and these things like, how
many times has it been
downloaded?
How many books are
out there on it?
How many companies
are using it?
Things like that.
And so they get this list
together and they sort them in
that order.
You'll find at the top there's
of course, Java, all of the C
type languages, like C,
C++, C sharp, PHP.
And then around six and seven,
you kind of see Python
alternating with objective
C as you can
probably imagine why.
So hopefully we end up
winning overall.
But one interesting factoid is
that it's actually won the
language of the year twice.
It's actually the only language
that has taken that
honor twice, or at least
more than once.
People in the Linux community
seem to like it as well, so
it's been winning a lot
of awards as of late.
And so you'll probably see
that trend continuing.
But Python isn't just
restricted to Linux.
You can actually get Python
on most every platform.
So if you have a Mac or a
Linux box, you actually
already have Python installed.
So the only users that
really have to go and
download it our PC users.
But yeah, exactly.
And in all of the exotic
platforms that you can't even
imagine, it kind of blew my mind
when I was told that the
Sony PlayStation and Nintendo
GameCube back then had Python
on it too, or people
imported it.
So it's been gaining
mindshare.
A couple of announcements that
came out over the last couple
of years that have also kind
of made people jerk their
heads, do a double-take.
Like, oh, Python.
Now I've heard of it.
One of them was when App Engine
came out, three years
ago, believe it or not, Google
App Engine is three years old.
And that launch with Python as
its first language supported.
And it included some of
Django, framework
and it still does.
Another announcement that has
been going on over the last
few years, has been
a change at MIT.
And their first undergraduate
course that incoming freshmen
get exposed to, they have
switched their class to
building robotics and
doing robotic work.
And the library that they use
is written in Python.
And so a lot of people were
completely shocked because the
headlines were MIT Switches
from Scheme to Python.
And as a computer scientist, I
definitely respect Scheme and
I think it's definitely more
of a pure, functional
programming language that you
should learn before going to
something more practical
like Python.
So that's maybe not that big of
news, but to the bloggers
and the media, everybody just
grabs onto that and says, oh
my gosh, Python must
be popular now.
All right, so where did
Python come from?
So several decades ago Guido was
at the Math and Computing
Research Institute in Holland.
He was working on the Amoeba
distributed operating system.
And he wanted a tool to write
lots of apps with and to do
system tasks and things
like that.
But when you're on an
experimental operating system,
there's really not
a lot of support.
So his choices were either using
C or the Bourne Shell.
Now, doing things in C, can
you imagine writing like a
little sys admin
script using C?
A little bit of overkill,
right?
So before that he actually
worked on another language
called ABC, which was going to
be like the next generation
educational language to teach
kids how to program.
And so what he really wanted to
have was something that had
a simple syntax, but had the
system capabilities of C.
And so that's sort of
the foundation of
how Python got started.
And he started working on it
around the holidays in 1989.
Another interesting factoid is
that Python is named after the
British Comedy Troupe and not
a snake, even though snakes
appear on 85% of all Python
books out there.
So I mentioned ABC and Python's
place with education.
It is again, heavily inspired
by ABC, this simple, yet
robust syntax.
But there is a strong belief
in education as well.
One of the essays that Guido
wrote back then was computer
programming for everybody.
And this proposal actually
ended up
getting funding as well.
But his belief is that
programming is a basic skill.
I mean it's something that
should be taught to children
at the same time they're
learning
how to read and write.
Now the whole purpose is not
the turn everybody into
software engineers.
It would be kind of scary
if the world was
full of software engineers.
But the thing is, look at how
you guys live every day.
When you go home, your everyday
life has some sort of
programming.
You've got to cook your dinner
in the microwave, you've got
to set your thermostat.
You've got to learn how to
use your cell phone.
You've got to program
your TiVo to record
your favorite shows.
There's some of programming.
So the main idea is that you
should learn programming.
Not, again, to be a software
engineer, but the fact that it
is a basic skill that people
have to have every day.
There was one great
story actually.
I don't know how many of you
guys grew up in America.
But in high school there's a
computer science advanced
placement exam.
And there was this instructor
from Washington D.C.
area, Jeff Elkner.
And he recounted the story of
how he has to take two years
of C++ to teach this to high
school kids in order to
prepare them for this exam.
Can you imagine how excited
the kids were
learning C++ for two years?
So the kids were dropping out,
they were losing interest. All
the girls left.
And so what he did was he
actually replaced the first
year with Python and the
retention was better, the
morale was better, people
were able to learn.
The students were able to
learn C++ much quicker.
They did better on the exam.
So that was a really
inspiring story.
So again, related to teaching
kids how to program, people
ask me, so what are some of the
programming languages that
people use to teach kids
how to program?
So we have Scratch, which
is based off of
Squeak from Alan Kay.
I don't know if you guys have
seen that, but it basically
teaches you programming by
having you build jigsaw
puzzles and snapping
pieces together,
which is really cool.
And that came out of MIT.
And then Alice is another
popular language that
originally came from University
of Virginia.
It was written in Python and it
migrated eventually over to
Carnegie Mellon.
Python's in that
list of course.
When I learned Basic many, many
eons ago, I learned Basic
on Commodore machines.
And some high schools actually
also teach kids how to program
using Flash and Action Script.
Now, that may make you kind of
think about it, but don't
think too hard about that.
And so when I go to schools and
I talk to kids, they ask
me, so, what are the programming
languages that you
grown-ups use to get work
done every day?
So that list is up on top.
So the usual C family
of languages, Java,
PHP, Python, and Ruby.
And of course, it's not as
surprising, you must have
already noticed that Python
shows up in both lists.
So the conclusion is, if you
don't know Python and it was
made for children, and you're
a technical professional, I
don't think it's going to be
that hard for you to be able
to pick up Python.
So that's the whole point.
If you've never seen any Python
code before, here's a
quickie demo.
And again, even if you've never
seen one line of Python
before, you should be able to
kind of figure out generally
what this is doing.
So the first thing you'll notice
is that instead of
using curly braces to delimit
blocks of code width, it uses
indentation.
Now for me coming from C and
Java and PHP, at first that
made me kind of shiver.
But after four months,
I was OK again.
I just needed to kind
of recover.
And when you realize that it's
an impossible thing to have a
dangling [? ELs ?]
problem, that's when you truly
appreciate this because your
[? EL ?]
statement has to belong to
one of those two if.
And it's the one that it lines
up closest with, or has to
line up exactly with.
So you can see that this
is a function.
Def is the keyword the
creates a function.
I'm going to create an integer
with the value 10.
I don't have to predeclare
anything.
It's dynamically typed.
I'm going to open a
file for write.
You can already use your
imagination and think, oh,
this must be exception handling
in case this file
can't be opened--
if this disk didn't exist or I
didn't have write permissions,
I'm going to get an error and
jump back from this function.
Once everything goes through
OK, we have a for loop.
And the for loop uses the range
built in function and if
you're coming from a language
where the for loop is a
traditional counting loop,
you'll be familiar with int i
equals 0, i is less than
10, i plus plus.
So in Python you would rewrite
the same thing by just copying
those numbers down into the
range function in their
appropriate slots.
And you'll get the
same effect.
Now the for loop in Python is
more like a shell script for
each statement where you're
iterating over
objects, not counting.
So the range function was
created to be able to help
Python simulate a
counting loop.
And then we just output to
the file, i times factor.
And I do a quick check to see
if i is divisible by 2.
Is there a remainder?
And if there isn't, then
it's an even number.
If not, it's an odd number.
And those of you who are really
sharp will probably
notice that if I multiply any
number by 10 it's always going
to be even.
So double check that.
And then you close the
file at the end.
Fairly straightforward, right?
For those of you who are new
to Python, was that OK?
Everybody able to absorb it?
Not too bad.
I mean the code is a little bit
more crowded than I wanted
to, but I wanted to show you as
many different things and
not make it too overly
complex.
All right, so community.
So that's Guido right there
in the red if you
didn't guess by now.
OK, so he's a fearless leader.
One of the really good things
about a programming language
that nobody ever talks about
is the community.
Now when you're learning a
language and getting involved
and you have questions, you
don't want to get onto a
newsgroup where people are
completely yelling at you,
they're criticizing you, they're
laughing at you.
That's not really fun.
So in general, the Python
community is very open,
welcome to people.
Whether you're a new programmer
or you're a refugee
from another programming
language like Ruby.
There's one newsgroup, there's
an IRC channel, and even if
you still are a little bit
timid, there's another mailing
list called Tutor, which
is really great.
Sometimes I volunteer on that
when I get a chance.
But that's a mailing list
specifically made for people
who are not only new to Python,
but also perhaps, new
to programming as well.
The general personality of
people in the Python
community-- we don't really
fight that much, we don't say,
our language is the greatest
on earth--
even though it is.
And we do know the flaws of
our favorite language.
I think that's very important.
And we do have strong debates.
Hopefully they're mostly
non-destructive.
And because the community is
so open and welcome, that
means conferences are easily
attendable by anybody, by
everybody in this audience.
PyCon is the main one that we
have here in North America.
But there are also localized
PyCons around the world.
There's also EuroPython, which
I would recommend you guys go
to if you can.
It's going to be in Florence
next month.
So I'm pretty excited be
going there myself.
And then OSCON, The O'Reilly
Open Source Convention that
takes place in Portland
in July.
I'll be there as well, so if you
can't make it to Florence
then go up to Portland so
I can see you guys.
If you're a beginner,
tutorials are great.
In fact, tutorials are so
popular that we actually
started to do two days
of tutorials.
I've never heard of that
at a conference before.
But it could be because
I don't go to enough
conferences.
But all of the PyCons are
grassroots efforts; they're
all done by volunteers.
There's even financial aid to
help you guys afford to go
there, whether it's paying for
hotel, or travel, or what not.
And we also have grants because
again, we're a very
open and diverse community and
want to keep it that way.
All right, so some of you guys
may have heard of some of
these more well-known Python
programming projects.
I'm not going to go over them
all, but they kind of indicate
to you what types of breadth
exist as far as software
support goes.
All kinds of things for
numerical processing and
working in different
environments, working with
databases, testing frameworks
and things like that.
[INAUDIBLE]
WESLEY CHUN: It's
in white font.
So yeah, so that's
the only problem.
What you should really should
be asking is, where are all
the web frameworks?
I couldn't put them on this
page, so they had
to have their own.
Because Python is a language
that has more web frameworks
than keywords.
And that quote is old.
There's at least twice as many
now than he realized.
So yeah, lots of different
things.
And so based on all the things
that I just showed you, you
can use Python for all of these
things and many things
that are not listed here.
I mean, I have a list
of things that
completely blew my mind.
When you go to a Python
conference and you hear about
these things, it really makes
you wonder like how we didn't
hear about these things.
So Python is used to map sparse
galaxies with, it's
used to analyze weather
patterns, to control
underwater robots.
And here's a really good one,
to help interpolate damaged
musical scores from
the 19th century.
Crazy stuff.
And the good news is that most
of these types of apps can be
done just by downloading
Python because it
is batteries included.
Yes, in certain cases you'll
have to go and download third
party stuff, but most of the
time you don't have to.
At least you can get started
without the third party stuff.
All right, so now that I've
told you a lot about the
language, let's talk about some
places that do use Python.
Not at Google first. I've used
it at lots of places.
Because like I said,
I've been doing
Python for like 14 years.
And I've done all kinds
of crazy stuff.
So one of the first things
I've done was
while working at Yahoo.
And now, a lot of people don't
realize this but we actually
built Yahoo Mail using Python
about 14 years ago.
Two-thirds of it was Python, the
back end mail store was a
little bit of C++.
But all of the middle ware and
all of the front end, we
actually custom made our own web
framework before that term
even existed.
And there are only about 9 or
10 of us and we built the
whole thing in about
half a year.
And you're probably wondering
about the image.
The original version was
called Rocket Mail.
Does anybody remember that?
OK.
Who still uses their Rocket
Mail account?
Not the refresh of it a couple
of years that Yahoo did.
OK, that's great.
We were working there and then
Yahoo decided they liked web
based email and they acquired us
instead of Hotmail because
we focused on having a better
user experience than Hotmail.
So another thing that I've done
is I've worked at another
company called IronPort, which
was acquired by Cisco.
And they built a hardware
appliance that filtered email
for spam and viruses.
And we used the custom made
version of Python and we were
able to process 500,000 email
messages per hour.
So it was a pretty cool thing.
It's not exactly this box.
I can't show you a picture
of the real box.
But I have some ex-coworkers in
the audience here that can
vouch for this.
So that's a little bit
different than--
well, I guess it's related
to email as well.
But more on the hardware side.
Before I came to Google,
I worked at Slide.
So we do Facebook games.
So my career has been internet
and networking and all that
stuff so far, but then the
craziest thing that I've never
done with Python is to write
software for doctors to help
analyze patients with
spinal fractures.
Very different.
I learned a lot about medicine
and I was always curious why
they hired me.
Because I told them I had
no medical background.
And said, well, you know what?
It's a lot easier to find a
Python person and teach them
medical stuff than it is to
find a medical person and
teach them programming.
So I go OK.
So anyway, if you need to know
anything about osteoporosis
and your spine, come talk
to me afterwards.
We also have some other
software that I wasn't
responsible for that
[? thioridazine ?]
knee cartilage stuff.
So as a software engineer,
I'm not that great at
documenting my code.
So Python had to do something
really crazy to my brain in
order make me want
to write a book.
Yeah, it just completely
changed my life.
When I was learning Python,
I never had--
there were only two books
on the market.
And none of them were what I was
looking for because I was
a software engineer.
I knew how to program in C and
Java and Tikal and Perl and I
wanted to learn Python
really well.
So that's the motivation.
One of the books I wanted to
highlight is the Django book
that I worked on with
two other authors.
The thing that's interesting
about that book is that there
were three of us.
We had never been together
physically, when
writing this book.
We did the whole thing
in plain text.
We used version control.
We used a make file.
We used markdown.
And then we had Python
drive the whole book.
We used Python to compile the
book, to suck in the source
code, and even to run unit tests
across the source code
before it embedded
it into the book.
And then, we used Python to
generate the HTML and PDF that
we eventually sent
to the publisher.
So that's another use case
for Python that's very
interesting.
Python's used at lots
of other companies.
Animation, it's pretty big
apparently because Disney,
Pixar, and Dreamworks uses it.
All of the Lucas companies
use it.
Hardware oriented companies,
like VMware, Broadcom, QNX,
they use it.
Social companies use it.
Linux companies use it.
And of course, the government
uses it.
And you can tell this is the
government because they're all
acronyms. So the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration, they run the
National Weather Service.
So they're also a
primary user.
And then we think that
the NSA uses it, but
they won't tell us.
So as you can kind of get a
sense, Python is pretty
popular with startups.
We've got many y-combinator
companies use it.
I think for one main reason:
very, very fast development.
And when you're running on
finite time, you need to be
first to market.
So they're the ones that are
helping adopt whatever the web
framework of the day is.
And a lot of companies
sort of have an
anti-marketing campaign.
They're really reluctant to
admit they used Python.
These days you can't really do
that that much because you're
actually looking
for engineers.
So you actually have to put
them in your job listings.
But back in the old days, when
we were at Yahoo Mail, which I
was going to give a talk at
how we use Python to build
Yahoo Mail with, but management
pretty much said no.
Because there's too much
competition out there.
Like Info Seek, Lycos, Excite,
and we just don't want them to
know we use it.
So I was not allowed to say
anything back then.
Of course since our acquisition
by Yahoo, we have
since ported it to C++ and
PHP and all that stuff.
But back in the old days, it was
just like well, it gave us
a strategic advantage over
the competition.
So we don't want to
say anything.
And you would do the same too,
if you had a startup.
All right, so now we get
to what you guys
actually came here for.
What do you want to hear about
Python and Google?
So it is recognized
as an official
language at the company.
And what that means is that you
can deploy Python code to
production servers.
C++ is the primary development
language, but there also needs
to be some sort of tools and
scripting language that gets
paired with C++.
You can't do everything
in C++.
Java actually came later, so
Python and C++ were a nice
pair back in the early days.
In fact, believe it or not,
Python was used at Google
before the company
even existed.
So back in the original paper
that Larry and Sergey did,
they actually mention in their
original paper that their
original web crawlers
and the URL servers
were done in Python.
So you can get access
to the paper there.
But it's very interesting to
know that Python has been
around before the
company existed.
Another quote, as the company
was growing, Peter Norvig
again, he made a quote.
And that was that, "Python has
always been an important part
of Google." Actually, he even
told me in person, I was
talking to him the other week,
and he said, yeah, Python was
here before I got here.
And I look at his employee ID
number, it's pretty low.
I'm like wow.
That's pretty incredible.
So another thing is that a lot
of the Python community
members are also Googlers
as well.
Besides myself and Guido,
Alex Martelli.
You may know that he's the
author of Python in a Nutshell
and The Python Cookbook.
He also works at Google.
Jim Hugunin, he created Jython
and Iron Python.
Fredrik did the current
version of the regular
expression engine and the PIL,
Python Imaging Library.
So many members of
the community
actually work at Google.
So Google has a strong
relationship with the language
and the Python software
foundation.
And Google is also committed to
the language because it's
always sponsoring Python
conferences of various types.
And even if we're not
sponsoring, we're always
sending speakers to
these conferences.
And of course, we also
employ the BDFL.
Like Guido, like myself, like
Python, Google also believes
in education.
In fact, the internal
training course--
internal Python training course
that some of us give--
has been externalized for
the general public.
So if you guys want to get
access to the labs, lectures,
videos and lessons of this class
that we take inside the
walls at Google, you can
go and check it out at
that link up there.
And there are also a bunch of
tech talks that have been
given at Google about Python
over time, and you can get
access to those over
there too.
All right, so what are some of
the products that use Python?
So there's Google, App Engine,
there's YouTube, there's
code.google.com, and a bunch
of open source libraries.
So these are all the
things I can say.
There's of course, plenty of
things that I can't say.
But let's start at the bottom,
take a look at some of these
open source libraries.
So Protobufs is a pretty
well-known library.
If you've never heard of it
before, just think of is as
being able to serialize
structured data.
Kind of like XML and JSON,
but more efficient.
We use it a lot for
communicating to and from
client and server.
And you can go and check
out the library at that
link at code site.
We also have the Google Data
Protocol client library
written in Python, as well as
other languages like Java and
C++ and .net and a bunch
of other clients.
But there's also one
specifically for Python that
let's you access your
Google data.
You know, such as what you have
in analytics, calendar,
maps, contact, spreadsheets.
Even other Google
properties, like
Blogger, Picasa and YouTube.
And you can get access to
the GDP library there.
Code.google.com.
If you're not familiar with it,
you should all be because
you guys are here at IO.
So you guys are all
Google developers.
This is the main website
for all of you guys.
This is where all the
documentation is, all the
tools, downloads, all
the code samples.
And code.google.com also has a
source code project hosting.
App Engine.
So I mentioned earlier that
App Engine launched with
Python back in 2008 as the
first supported language.
One of the reasons why Python
was chosen was because it has
a simple VM and it was easily
wrappable in C++ and be able
to put in a sandbox.
Also, it's easy to
get started.
You know, App Engine's goal is
to take a lot of complexity of
creating apps and hosting
apps away from you.
And so one of the ways of doing
that in addition to all
of the hardware and the
infrastructure stuff that we
try to take away from you, is
having to spend a lot of times
building apps.
So Python again, really
encourages rapid development.
So that's another way that we're
trying to help out at
having you be able to create
and deploy apps quicker.
And when it came out, it caused
quite a shock in the
Python and Django communities.
We were all blown away;
it was incredible.
And one of the last things I
wanted to point out is that it
really does not require you to
have a CS or an engineering
degree in order to be effective
in the language.
I think that's part of the open
to all type of mentality
that the language has.
Normally I would give a demo.
I'm going to run out of time
today, so I'll skip the demo.
But if you guys don't know App
Engine at all, just go to
code.google.com/appengine and
you'll be able to download the
stuff and be able
to play with.
There's an online tutorial
as well.
All right, so let's talk for a
few minutes about YouTube,
They're also, a very being
user of Python.
In fact, they're such a big
user of Python, almost the
entire YouTube site as see
by you, uses Python.
Whether you're viewing a video
or whether you have software
that controls a front end and
templates for the website, or
when you're administrating your
videos, all the back end
API servers, the batch tools,
all the test utilities, or if
you have to access any of the
YouTube canonical data, that's
all done with Python.
And even if something is not
Python, the glue code to put
that thing together is Python.
So Python is everywhere
at YouTube.
In fact, like Google, Python was
around at YouTube before
YouTube was at Google.
There was a small team, they
really loved Python.
Ironically, when I was at
IronPort, we actually worked
across the street
from YouTube.
So two hardcore Python companies
next to each other
in San Bruno, right
off of 380.
Yeah, it was a small team
that loved Python.
They felt that it gave the
engineers a sense of
discipline and honor without
having the compiler police
there to monitor them.
Their early architecture,
they used Apache with
Mod_python and MySQL.
Kind of similar to when I did
Yahoo Mail, we actually also
had Apache.
But we used the old [? POI ?]
Apache module back then.
And this actually lasted them
for quite a while and it would
survive longer than
one would think.
Until the user base grew
and they started to
need to scale more.
The way they scaled was, every
time they would run into a
bottleneck, they would either
somehow work around it, or fix
it, or get rid of it.
They believe in using good
components, good open source
tools that have been tried and
tested, and to further improve
on them, to optimize them.
They learned really well how to
balance machine resources
and they did a lot of caching
and they had to scale MySQL in
a horizontal way that I don't
know too much about.
So I'll defer you to go
talk to a YouTube
engineer about that.
But they did do a lot of
Python optimization.
And anytime they ran into any
type of performance issues
with Python, they would port
that code directly into C.
So one of the examples is they
used to do a lot of hashing
using Python.
Well, you just take that out,
replace it with a few lines of
C and that's not an
issue anymore.
Next road bump.
They simplified algorithms that
should have been not as
complex and they did thinks to
help improve how efficient
that the developers were.
When they do all of these
optimizations for scale-aware
code, they actually push all
this stuff under the covers so
that the regular software
engineer doesn't always have
to know everything
about scaling.
They get a simple call like this
that's very easy to code,
very easy to understand,
and that's great.
However, the thing is this
doesn't give you a right to go
and be sloppy and become
a memory hog.
You still have to be aware
of what you're doing.
Sometimes I always tell people
that, you need to really
program in a low-level language
like C or C++ in
order to really appreciate all
of the memory management that
Python and Java give you.
So just don't be too loose
with your morals.
So the bottom line at YouTube is
that Python provides a lot
of flexibility.
It gave them rapid development
as well.
You'll hear rapid development
over and over
again in this talk.
And simplicity.
And their secret to success is
just-in-time optimization.
You run as hard as you can.
When you have to optimize, you
go and do it, and then you
move onto the next thing.
They like to take reliable
open source software and
customize and optimize
as they need.
So people always question,
can Python really scale?
So some stats to think
about from YouTube.
They get over 2 billion
views a day.
200 million of those
are mobile views.
And there are about
35 hours of video
uploaded every minute.
And actually, the
real numbers are
actually bigger than these.
These are just the numbers
that we can say.
So if you're curious, more
curious about how Python at
YouTube scaled with Python, then
take a look at that talk
given by one of the engineers
at YouTube.
It's a very, much more in-depth
technical talk.
So if you want to kind of dig a
little deeper, I suggest you
go and check that out.
So as I kind of already alluded
to on the previous
slide, proceed with caution.
Yes, I'm enthusiastic, now you
should be enthusiastic about
Python because I made you so.
But you can't just drop it in
where C++ and Java are.
You can't just like swap those
out and expect everything to
stay the same.
Because in general, interpreted
languages just
don't compare to compiled
languages.
Of course, one exception
is PyPy.
I don't know if you guys
have heard of that.
But that is the Python
interpreter written in a
restricted statically-typed
version of Python.
And believe it or, no it,
actually beat C Python in most
benchmarks.
So keep an eye on that project
because that's probably going
to be another shocking thing
that comes down the line if
you've never heard
of it before.
So anyway, yes, Python has big
strengths and they are
flexibility and rapid
development.
Those things are
the key things.
Performances and scalability
are also important too, but
that's not the point.
The point is to be
first to market.
You get there, then you port
or optimize as necessary in
order for you to succeed.
Other places that Python shows
up, originally the Google
Build system was
done in Python.
There are a gazillion system
administration tools that I
can't even begin to count that
are written in Python.
The code review tool that
engineers use to do review and
then check-ins, that's
also done in Python.
QA and testing, automation,
lots of SWIG.
If you don't know what SWIG is,
that's the library that
helps you wrap C and
C++ code in Python.
And of course, there's lots
of App Engine apps.
Many of you guys are external
App Engine developers, but
believe it or not, there's a lot
of App Engine use within
Google as well.
And so I invite you guys to
come see Ben Fried's talk
tomorrow, Coding
for the Cloud.
And there, he and his team
will explain how they use
Google App Engine to
build apps to help
run Google, the company.
I think that's tomorrow
morning.
So the last part of the
talk, Python and You.
So if you're new to Python, you
want to get started, of
course python.org is
the main website.
Don't go to python.com.
I think some porn site took
it over at some point.
But maybe that domain has
finally been reclaimed by
something else.
But all of the docs,
downloads, and
tutorials are there.
Book suggestions.
Of course, I recommend
Core Python.
Not just because I wrote it, but
the main purpose of that
is to give you the most
comprehensive dive into Python.
I want you to learn
it quickly and as
comprehensively as possible.
If you don't have time for
that, my colleague, Mark
Pilgrim, he's written a book
called Dive into Python.
And that's what I call a quick
dive into the language.
So I don't think he's here, but
Mark, you can jump up if
you're here.
And if you have kids or you're
a beginner and you want to
learn how to program,
take a look at that
book, which is great.
It's called Hello World and
it's a book written by an
engineer and his eight year old
son, so it's got a kid's
perspective, which
is really cool.
Lots of online videos.
The show me do videos
are just one set.
But if you look around, there's
all kinds of tutorials
and videos that you can use.
And for community, there's a
newsgroup like I said, the
Tutor mailing list. As well as
take a look at the upcoming
PyCon conferences.
Like I said, the most recent
ones coming up are
EuroPython and OSCON.
And I think PyCon in Asia
Pacific is coming
up in June as well.
So if you want to go to
Singapore, hit up a Python
conference.
So now I have to give
you a warning.
We are at the crossroads
of Python.
So you guys have arrived at just
the right time, I think.
There are actually two
versions of Python.
There's a Python 2, which is
the current version that
everybody's using.
There's also Python 3, which
is the next generation.
And it is evidence that Python
is continuing to evolve.
Now, one of the things that
people note and people say and
all of the FUD comes
up is that it's
backwards-incompatible.
Yes, that's really scary because
of the two big words.
But the thing is, the language
isn't changing so much that if
you learn Python 2 you can't
do 3, or vice versa.
It's not like that.
It's not like the changes are
so big that it's causing the
community to fragment.
It is new.
It's still a little rough
on the edges,
but it's usable now.
And so, just don't freak out.
So on the earlier slide I showed
you Hello World, but I
need to show you Hello World
in Python 3 now.
So obviously, if you're going
to change print from a
statement to a function, that's
going to break like 95%
of all the code up
there, right?
So of course, it's
backwards-incompatible.
But is it that hard?
Is that really earth-shattering?
Not really.
Of course, I'd have to tell
you there's a third way of
doing it and that's more lower
level if you want to really
use standard in, standard
out, standard area
you can do that too.
But you've got to import the
sys module to do that.
So there's three different ways
of doing Hello World.
Python's philosophy is there
should be only one right way
of doing things.
So this is just one
minor exception.
In other words, don't
freak out.
Whether you learn Python
2 or Python 3, it
doesn't really matter.
Just pick one.
Which one should you pick?
So yeah, instead of panicking,
get excited and do stuff.
We don't have time to panic.
So if you want to know where to
start, if you're completely
new to the language, you don't
have any dependencies, you
should start with Python 3
because that is going to be
the future.
If you have existing software or
you have existing books and
tutorials, most books
and tutorials are
still in Python 2.
So if you have some baggage,
then stick with Python 2.
Like I said, doesn't matter.
Either one is fine.
What did I go over
in the talk?
I mentioned that Python's a
great first language for
people to learn how
to program with.
Two of its greatest features are
that it encourages rapid
development because of the
simplistic syntax.
It's very flexible, there are
many applications that are
written in Python that are
out there already.
Specifically at Google, as
well as not at Google.
Python is pretty popular and
will continue to be.
There are many libraries and
tools that are written in
Python and when you
go and download--
when you go and look at the
archives and repositories of
all the software, there's a lot
of variety of things that
are out there.
And Python has a really strong
relationship with education,
and same goes from
Google as well.
And of course, a big plug.
Google's always hiring
strong developers.
So if you're looking for work,
then come talk to one of us.
I'd love to meet users.
Come talk to me.
I'm going to be speaking at
these conferences, I also have
a Python training course in
May or later this month.
But generally, I'm accessible
at lots of conferences.
I'm either talking about Python
and/or App Engine.
If you're curious about the
slide generator, I wrote that
using the os, sys, time,
and Tkinter modules.
I also used the Python
extensions for Windows, so
that I could actually connect
to PowerPoints.
People have been asking for this
for years, so I promise
it will be in the third
edition of my book.
And I'll also put it out
as open source as well.
All right, thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
WESLEY CHUN: Feel free to
come up to the mics.
Feel free to ask a question.
Yes, sir.
Hi.
So let's pretend there's a
hypothetical startup with a
hypothetical team of smart
developers who are quite split
on using Python or Ruby for a
software as a service, high
availability, whatever,
whatever product.
What are some words of wisdom
you could give to grant weight
to the Python decision there?
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Oh dang, I
was going to be completely
impartial about that.
You can be impartial.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: And say with
the dynamic language
you can't go wrong.
That's good as well.
It's all hypothetical.
Maybe.
WESLEY CHUN: I don't know.
Do you like Rails or Django?
That's a good question.
I know a good number of
engineers in the community, a
lot of my colleagues actually
know Python and Ruby.
So they're actually a really
good audience to ask, but many
of them will say, I'm pretty
flexible but most of the time
I'll lean towards Python because
there isn't anything
that I can't do in Python.
And they're flexible.
But they feel a little more at
ease with Python and they say
the syntax is a little
bit easier.
Some people have really
strong feelings
against Ruby's syntax.
I don't think it's that bad.
But some people do.
I will just say prototype a
medium-sized project in both
and gather feedback.
Thank you.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Another
thought about that topic is if
you ever imagine doing something
that is not web
programming and you imagine
maybe using some other third
party software in addition to
the language, there is a very
wide array of software for
Python that I think is--
Python is used in many areas
besides web programming and
Ruby is a little bit of a
one-trick pony in that sense.
Ruby on Rails is pretty much
synonymous with Ruby.
So as long as you're sure that
you're never going to do
anything besides web
programming, it probably
doesn't matter which language
you choose.
WESLEY CHUN: Good point.
Yes sir.
So you've probably heard of
the Scripting Language for
Android project, which has
been around for a little
while, which allows for Python
apps to be made for Android.
But currently, obviously not
nearly as much you can do with
that as with standard
Java apps.
So I was wondering if Google
has any plans of extending
that or integrating it into
to Android SDK at all, or
anything like that?
WESLEY CHUN: That's a tough
question because we don't
represent the Android.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Yeah.
You should really ask the
Android people about that.
WESLEY CHUN: We would love for
that to happen, though.
Then you should try to do it.
Thanks.
WESLEY CHUN: Sure.
Who's next?
I think you're next.
Yeah, will App Engine support
Python 3 at some point?
WESLEY CHUN: Will App
Engine support
Python 3 at some point?
At some point, yes.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM:
Most likely yes.
I mean unless the App Engine
product is going to go under
in the next five years, it
will support Python 3.
When?
Well, we're looking at Python
2.7 first at the moment, which
is actually quite a huge step
in the right direction.
WESLEY CHUN: It is.
One thing that I didn't mention
in this talk is that
starting with Python 2.6,
they're rolling in a lot of
Python 3 features.
They're back porting
these features.
So 2.6 and 2.7 are really good
tools to actually coding in a
more Python 3 flavor.
Why the delay?
WESLEY CHUN: Pardon?
WESLEY CHUN: Why the delay?
Well, when you have a
backwards-incompatible future
release, it takes a lot of
time to do this porting.
You know, I'm going
to call a decade.
That's 10 years.
That's a lot of time.
So Python 3.0 came
out in 2008.
So I don't think the entire
world will be--
I'm sure he wants it faster.
But I don't think the entire
world will be on Python 3
until 2018.
So the thing is, it's not Python
2 is end of light.
So the idea is that even
2.6 and 3.0 were
developed in parallel.
So there are actually two teams
that are working on it
simultaneously.
It's not like 2.7 been cut
off and it's dead now.
That's not the case.
So it's not as much of a delay
as it is ease of migration.
Thanks.
WESLEY CHUN: Go ahead.
In a couple areas of the Python
community, I see that
there's a lot of not invented
here syndrome.
My two biggest gripes
are in web
frameworks and event loops.
We already have Twisted, but
we still felt the need to
invent Diesel and Tornado.
Frameworks I think
are even worse.
People are inventing new web
frameworks every week, simply
because they don't
like the way that
the other one templates.
What do you guys
think of that?
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: I think it's
great because it just shows
how easy it is to develop
one of those things.
And so I think, let there
be competition.
Let lots of people try different
ways of doing the
same thing.
Something like Twisted is the
effective 800-pound gorilla of
event handling frameworks.
Anyway, it's never going to
be in the standard library
because it's just a completely
different level of coding.
I mean Twisted is a project
with its own release cycle
that would be very hard to be
adjusted to the core Python
release cycle.
So it will always be
its separate thing.
There's no worry that the core
will sort of take over the
market for, the niche for an
event programming framework.
At the same time.
it's good that there's
competition that people try
different ways of sort of
doing the same thing.
I say let there be
more choice.
WESLEY CHUN: Right.
The market winner will
show up eventually.
Isn't [INAUDIBLE]
still in the 3.0 standard
library?
WESLEY CHUN: I think so.
And I think it's been
maintained.
Somebody's been patching
it recently I believe.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: That is the
only reason that is in the
standard library.
Is that there are some people
who use it and we don't want
to sort of be gratuitously
backwards compatible.
But that is certainly not what
we recommend people use.
OK.
Thank you.
WESLEY CHUN: It was also created
by one of our ex
IronPort co-workers too.
Yeah, I know.
WESLEY CHUN: Great, thanks.
Go ahead.
So clearly, Python is the
superior language and has
seniority at Google.
How is it that Java ended up
in Android and GWT and many
other projects as opposed
to Python?
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Is that
a serious question?
Personally, I don't prefer
to develop in
Java, but I love GWT.
It was kind of a serious
question.
WESLEY CHUN: There's Pyjamas.
Well, it doesn't work well with
the GWT compiler, right?
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Well, sort
of the reality is that the
choice of language is
often a very sort of
non-rational choice.
And people tend to go with where
it's easiest to hire
lots of programmers.
And that in many cases, has sort
of forced the choice for
Java in many specific
projects.
OK, fair enough.
Thank you.
WESLEY CHUN: Sir.
Yeah, hi.
So with an ecosystem of Python
interpreters emerging with C
Python versus PyPy and then
Unladen Swallow, whatever is
going on with that.
How long is the core development
going to be still
done with C Python where like
PyPy is really pulling ahead
in a lot of benchmarks?
I know it's not future complete
yet, but are there
any plans of incorporating these
other interpreters in
the core development so new
features come out on them at
the same time as other
interpreters?
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: That's not
really how it works.
Sort of core Python development
as we currently
think of it is really C
Python development.
It is a group of people who
choose to work on C Python.
What might eventually happen
is that more and more
individuals choose to contribute
to PyPy instead of
to C Python.
We have a fair number of
developers who split their
time between those
two versions.
Some who started out as C Python
developers are now PyPy
developers.
What I'm still sort of waiting
for, I mean personally, I am
like the opposite of
a speed freak.
I don't care particularly
how fast it runs.
So I'm not ever going to
contribute to something whose
focus is on making it run faster
and extremely, insanely
smart [INAUDIBLE]
optimizations.
It turns out that quite a few
users of Python sort of
currently still seem to think
the same way because C Python
is still more popular
than PyPy.
On the other hand, we do see
sort of some users move over
and I think that I don't
want the development
team to drive that.
I want the users
to drive that.
So if the users sort of start
showing a clear trend towards
PyPy, then it's possible that
eventually PyPy will sort of
compete head to head with
C Python at some point.
We may say, OK, there's no need
for both C Python and
PyPy because they are both
sort of feature complete.
Let's focus on one of them.
And then sort of the one that
is more modern and runs your
code faster would
be preferred.
Until then--
again, it's the same answer as
with the web frameworks.
Hooray for competition, hooray
for diversity, let's see where
it all leads.
WESLEY CHUN: Great.
Sir.
What insight can you give us
on the choice of Django for
App Engine as the web framework
that was chosen?
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: I think
it was a coincidence.
Anything else?
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: I mean it
was a fine coincidence.
OK.
Cool.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: We didn't do
a very careful comparison of
available web frameworks.
We probably would have decided
to write our own.
Which sort of for 50%,
we actually did.
Does Google use Psycho for any
of your projects, and do you
consider it safe?
Is it still being actively
developed?
It seemed like it kind of
got abandoned there.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: I think there
may be small pockets in
Google that still use Psycho.
I don't think that it's
very popular anymore.
For App Engine I certainly would
not consider it safe.
WESLEY CHUN: Same goes
for YouTube.
YouTube used to be a big user of
Psycho and that has kind of
wind down as well.
The lead developer of
Psycho has actually
gone on to do PyPy.
He's a lead developer
for PyPy now.
Yes sir.
We learned that this morning
App Engine will
also support Go.
So would you like to comment
on these [INAUDIBLE]
efforts within Google?
WESLEY CHUN: Are there
any Go App Engine
developer members here?
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: I didn't hear
the-- understand the last
half of the question.
WESLEY CHUN: He was just asking,
so Go was announced as
a third run time, what were the
decision making process
into deciding that?
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Oh, what led
to the decision to offer Go as
the third language
in App Engine?
That what actually purely the
Go team being really gung-ho
and doing it.
App Engine has lots of sort
of different parts of
infrastructure that the core App
Engine team takes care of.
And it sort of turns out that
language run times are
typically pushed by people who
are somewhat peripheral to the
App Engine team.
So the Java run time also was
initially developed by people
who weren't part of the
core App Engine team.
Now they are.
I wouldn't be surprised if
some Go people would also
become full-fledged members
of the App Engine team.
But currently that's
sort of wow, people
contribute to run time?
Great.
A new language, more choice.
That's the mantra again.
WESLEY CHUN: All right, that's
all we have time for.
So if you guys have any other
questions, just come see us
after the talk.